cork it's the miracle tree bark that's
found in everything from baseball bats
to spaceships but it's best known as the
last obstacle in your journey to drink
wine yes sometimes decor can can feel
like a chore no I'm not talking about
popping up in a wine bottle I'm talking
about how cork is harvested in the first
place by these guys manual cork
harvesters in Portugal it's a job so
difficult and yet so artful machines
have yet to render absolute welcome to
Portugal where cork is the national tree
cork is native to the Mediterranean
Basin but nowhere does it grow more than
here part of all have 35% of all our
trees in the world
this tree needs a very special
conditions of humidity and hot weather
since cork trees can live for 200 years
Gonzales trees are the exact same trees
his parents grandparents and
great-grandparents also care for
[Music]
the pork harvesting is a process that
can only be done by hand the man's work
always in team of tools first they cut
the tree like Taylor they draw the tree
with several cards to open the cork when
they threw the axe they also twist the
hand to open the cork after that with
the side of the blade they will open and
super the cork from the tree
[Music]
uncocks Tom desert sighs I talk about
pork and adequate water concurrent
across school or confirm is considered
odd she comes off you know dear completa
mental compartment arrested yesterday a
passenger a sample jarasandha Evod
manera de sin the pillows court massage
spa no free deserves
Oh long distance toad shock Moodle for a
scardy cat Madera personal menu
the men's learn from quite young to just
cut the cork and doesn't get the layer
of the cork tree if the men get the
layer that's a problem they will harm
the tree and open and enters for bugs
and other disease
[Music]
once a tree is harvested it won't be cut
again for another nine years this keeps
the bark healthy and the harvest
tradition alive for the generations to
come
to all our generations we take care of
our trees like we take care of our sons
this is very important for us
[Music]
you